you're in it it's heated you're just
going bam bam you're throwing the
punches at them you thrown the knees and
you're getting kid let's say someone's
on you and they're hitting you do you
actually know what's going on there's a
purely reflects that like can you are
you able to in that split second can you
process know what you're doing you know
what's going on your process how much as
process and how much is reflexive
usually like in it like when you get in
exchange the fastest ship math like if
we're in poom we'll get something we
start passing yeah it's its reaction you
reaction got it you're acting fast
what's the water on top pounding on the
internet that's thinking you can see it
coming it's tell you that's not a quick
pop like in exchange I mean like someone
throw something you counter and then you
count it hahahaha and then then you
start thinking again I mean it just it's
it's a quick it's really quick little
quick reaction moves and in that moment
in that moment what I thought why if I
beat or Belfort he finally came after me
in the third round cuz they told me he
had to win the round it came at me and
boom i sat among that right here that
was just a counter I just I was I was
reacting to him coming straight at me to
step up pop pop bang that was just
something that went through I mean you
have won the best of all time you if you
want to watch a highlights knockout
highlights just type in Chuck Liddell
knockout highlights it's nonstop you can
watch him and they're incredible but but
the thing I want to know about like in
the business world sometimes in a
business world you get hit okay and in
that moment you can't you can't teach a
dogfight to somebody if you got the
fight you got the fight
sometimes you see in your world somebody
gets hit and they back down and back up
and then don't come back to fight is
that instinct is that the fear is that
the not lack of dogfight do you see that
as a culture so why I say I say this all
the time was striking like I'll say that
guy doesn't like to get hit ya know when
I put what I mean by that is he's
unnecessarily afraid again Pulis it out
like this he's not reacting the way you
can be changed I you know from your
years of watching a bunch of fighters
can that actually be changed for
somebody
never tried to change that I mean it's a
funny question because I used to always
think mental toughness either a birdie
don't but I did a lot of studying on on
on teaching it and you know I think part
of it was for me I just when he came to
me by the time he came to me if you
didn't want mentally tough I didn't want
I it's too late I don't want it I'm not
I'm not gonna waste my time trying to
teach you how to be tough so I guess the
question would be more this way go back
to when you were in high school where a
guy was maybe our level or college we
were competing you said this guy's
actually he's pretty solid when I fight
this guy but his mental and emotional
toughness was a little bit less than
yours did you see somebody like they
said that guy never made it past a
certain level and you all continuing to
grow oh for sure when you put under that
pressure yeah you know two two choices
really breaking full when you come out
fighting if you're gonna succeed and I
think about anything you need to be that
guy that comes out fight teto tap two
strikes one time a funny story so we
were party talking about it and I forgot
you tap two strikes between Frank
Shamrock we're talking about this other
guy they've tapped to Beverly Silva like
two strikes he's getting strong can you
tap it I'm like yeah come on what a
[ __ ] can you believe that guy's tap two
strikes if I could think if you can
think the tap you can think you defend
yourself and try to get out of it can
you realize I'm talking to you I'm doing
a demo oh I'm sorry we're gonna walk
down I'm like oh [ __ ] he tapped it and
that moment you didn't know you didn't
think I didn't think I forgot the near
death the strike snap fight cuz you know
when they stopped that fight I went nuts
because I would that was right when I
first started training was helping him
training him ready for fight was a 45
Frank Shamrock
I was on the side I need to see him tap
I went nuts that they stopped the fight
I don't know it's almost over yeah he
already won he was one all the way he
won that rounds up to that oh no he
can't stop the fight why he stopped and
he's not hurt and then I don't eat app
he tapped
how have you ever tapped